good day everyone welcome and happy
November I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I'm proud to
welcome you to this edition of our 2023
2024 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 20 2016 the foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series
has focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme this year is focused on building
of Partnerships for generative AI
training and biomedical and clinical
research where every Friday we enjoy
presentations from a wide range of
leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging prominence
of AI based methods applied to
biomedical science data types indeed we
would like to remind folks that our 2023
2024 application cycle is open and we
encourage all Junior faculty working in
areas such as development of generative
AI based methods applied to biomedical
research and those Junior faculty
actively utilizing AI in their
biomedical teaching to consider applying
we believe this to be an exciting and
engaging program bringing together AI
platform velers and University level
Educators to better understand the power
promise and potential pitfalls
associated with the generative AI
explosion participants selected for our
biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these seminar
presentations as vital material in
culminating and our culminating
in-person manuscript and Grant
development Workshop to be held at the
bajia beachfront Resort located in Sunny
San Diego California in June of 2024
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Julian mcau who is a
professor at UC San Diego Julian does
work on the applications of machine
learning to problems involving
personalization and teaches courses on
personalized recommendations before
joining the department of computer
science and engineering at UC San Diego
in 2015 Dr mcau was a post-doctoral
researcher at Stanford University and he
earned his PhD from the Australian
National University in 2011 his research
focuses on the linguistic temporal and
social dimensions of opinions and
behaviors in social networks and other
online communities he harnesses data
science tools to increase understanding
of the facets of people's opinions the
processes that lead people to acquire
taste for Gourmet Foods and beers and
even the visual dimensions of how they
make fashion choices he is the author of
a recent book called personalized
machine learning published by Cambridge
University press and a fun fact in his
free time he likes riding bicycles and
Baroque keyboard isn't that nice that
somebody has free time it's not me
Julian but in continuing our 2023 2024
biomedical data science seminar series
theme Julian's lecture today is entitled
personalized Med um excuse me
personalized machine learning for
clinical natural language processing
where he will discuss his lab's
experience working at the interface
between NLP personalization and clinical
machine learning and following a short
overview of his research he will spend
the bulk of his talk describing his
experiences getting into clinical
research as a machine learning
researcher with no clinical experience
including navigating advising
collaboration fundraising data access
and more as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and if you're watching on
YouTube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2023 2024
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions they have by the
chat feature in their YouTube sessions I
will be synthesizing all these questions
and asking them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome Julian we are
really looking forward to your
presentation yeah thanks so much Jack
it's a lovely introduction um if there's
time at the end of the talk I'd be be
happy to place in bark for you you can
also check out my recital on my twitch
channel on my YouTube uh if you're into
barck keyboard like me um but other than
that we're going to talk
about um personalized machine learning
clinical natural language processing all
that good stuff today so what I'll try
and cover in this talk is a basic
overview of my lab so uh for what it's
worth my lab does not really do it's not
really a clinical machine learning or a
clinical research lab uh where a lab
that is adjacent to clinical research
and adjacent to clinical machine
learning so we we dip our feet in it a
lot but it's not exactly what we we do
as such uh and I'll talk about um why we
do some of it and why we don't do more
of it
um I'll I'll talk then about the stuff
we do in in clinical machine learning uh
so how our projects and collaborations
have worked so
far um other than that you know I was
sort of surprised to to get an
invitation from from this group to give
a talk given that I'm a little bit
distant from from Clinical work compared
to some of the speakers uh so I thought
I would spend the
time mostly talking about my experience
doing clinical research as a not
clinical person and how I got into that
uh and and some of the pitfalls around
working in that space uh especially as
like a a collaborator with medical
school people um how it went for me as a
as a junior faculty member sort of uh
Sage fatherly advice now that I'm so
much older and wiser than I was
before okay sounds good and it's you
know not a not a super long talk very
very spacious I'm happy to um take
questions and and and answer them as we
go if there are any anything I can
respond to quickly all right so what is
our lab like I said it's not really a um
clinical machine learning or clinical
research lab we are a lab that does
machine learning very broadly and we
work in this area that I kind of call
personalized machine learning where we
have lots of research themes that center
around
personalization which roughly speaking
means we
take machine learning ideas
from every area you can possibly
conceive of so natural language
processing computer Vision Audio um
music uh recommended systems uh fairness
and debiasing lots of clinical stuff and
we say how can
we adapt machine learning ideas from
those areas to topics that require lots
and lots of personalization so topics
where modeling the individual dynamics
of of the users or modeling the Dynamics
of the the people involved
is kind of critical to Building Systems
that perform well uh so yeah think about
not just uh models of images or text but
personalized models of images or text
you know why would you want a natural
language model to be personalized it
could it could respond to a speaker in a
more um empathetic manner um maybe you
could remember things about your uh
Persona or or facts about you it
could
um you know a personalized model of
images could do things like recommend
fashion and outfits to you uh and yeah
lots of settings in in clinical machine
learning where modeling the individuals
involved is really critical to
success okay
so you know at least lately the the
bread and butter of our research has
been recommended systems this is kind of
one of the core areas of of personalized
machine learning where you're
essentially doing nothing other than and
personalization right if you're building
a recommended system you're trying to
recommend movies on Netflix or products
on Amazon or something like
that all you're really doing is trying
to figure
out what are the preferences of each
individual user toward um various items
or various attributes of different items
uh you're trying to figure out how one
user differs from another user and how
users are similar to each
other okay so that's like the the bread
and butter of of personalization within
machine learning and lately it probably
won't surprise you to hear uh this line
of research has really been overtaken by
uh generative language modeling just
like everything else in machine learning
uh at least in the last year or so
nearly all of our Labs funding has
shifted over to problems related to
conversational recommended system we
used to do lots and lots of things and
then all the sponsors said oh we want to
get in on this um we want to get on this
generative language modeling boom it
seems like these kind of applications
where you can build things like
recommended systems that you can talk to
uh not 10 or 20 years out anymore but
maybe they're two or three years out
people are actually thinking about
deploying these kinds of things so we're
working on building these models that
will talk to users about their
preferences and and recommend things
that are relevant to their their context
or personalization Dynamics much like
you might get a recommendation from your
your spouse or or your friend if you're
trying to choose a movie or a restaurant
together or something like that um you
can think in your head a little bit uh
why this kind of thing might be relevant
to clinical machine learning or CL
clinical natural language processing
think of the kind of systems where we
would want dialogues between a user and
an agent and in which those dialogues
ought to be personalized so yeah on the
surface of it it's this very sort of
e-commerce is industrial type of
research but I don't think you have to
think too hard to to see the connection
to things like
um clinical
settings uh we also do lots of work on
other modalities of data and other
problems we do lots of work on on music
and audio like I said um also connected
to things like text to speeech where
we're trying to synthesize realistic
audio whether that means speech or or
music or anything like that um capturing
things like harmonic structure I mean
this is a bit of fun really I shouldn't
you know there's no there's no real
connection to the clinical research this
is something we like to do a lot of um
needless to say we we do this
essentially without any any funding on
on music the funding on music lags
behind funding on generative models for
language and images and clinical
research by quite a bit although I think
music is fairly important and worth
studying but anyway I digress
um lots of work on these sort of
multimodal problems this is a paper that
was kind
of building these models that that
simultaneously ingest data from text
images and audio uh so we can learn
these joint representations that allow
us to um do queries in one form to
extract data from another modality so
you can uh train it on a bunch of um
text images and videos and then you can
build these systems that allow you to do
natural language queries like you can
type in saxophone player and it will
extract the audio from a video of just
the saxophone player while removing the
background noise in a way that's like
largely
unsupervised again you can tangentially
imagine there are relationships between
this problem and and clinical settings
where you you might be simultaneously
collecting text um audio and video data
um and you might want to establish
connections between these different
components and you might want to isolate
different pieces of audio from video so
on and so
forth uh lots of work on kind of what I
would call core natural language
processing so just developing um you
know state-of-the-art models for
generative NLP uh being academics a lot
of our work is about developing compact
models since we can only afford so many
gpus this was one of our projects about
training uh kind of local llms so you
would distill uh smaller models from
large language models by making large
language models talk to themselves about
narrow topic so you can build this this
small compact language model that you
can deploy on your own video card or
something it is built from something
like chat GPT but you make chat GPT talk
to itself about a narrow setting so you
know for instance um clinical natural
language or something and then you get
kind of a small distilled version that
has performance close to chat GPT as
long as you're talking to it about this
this smaller topic that you've trained
it on
uh lots and lots of work in our lab is
also about
um machine learning fairness and machine
learning debiasing also Hot Topics
within clinical machine learning to make
the um the predictions or the outcomes
of of machine learning models and
interventions more more fair we've done
lots of this in the context of text
we've also done some of it in the
context of things like um hiring and
even admissions process within
universities so how can we use machine
learning models or how can we augment
human decisions with machine learning in
order to make outcomes more
fair uh and yeah tons and tons of other
stuff so I think I've given you a sense
of the flavor um we're not really tied
to any one methodology or domain of
machine learning the common feature is
that we tend to be dealing with data
generated by people where model the
Dynamics of the individuals involved is
kind of key to getting good performance
so yeah we've done lots of other stuff
uh this is just a a quick sample lots of
work on on on fashion recommendation
again probably not so relevant to this
to this crowd but something we've worked
on a ton uh we've done some work on
things like like uh recipe generation uh
recommendation for live streaming
platforms like twitch um some work on
things like uh
personalized self-driving cars so you
know you can imagine you want to build a
self-driving car that learns some policy
that is relevant to a particular user so
that it drives like they would drive
this is in the context of of
personalized cruise control so it sort
of learns how you would like to follow
other vehicles uh all kinds of stuff
like
that um you know other than that the the
main thing I Al is actually known for
boring though it may be is probably our
collection of uh benchmark data sets
focused around personalization and
recommendation and so on and so forth so
we've we've collected which is to say we
we've scraped from the web uh pretty
large number of uh interaction and
natural language data sets uh from all
kinds of domains but mostly from
recommended systems um and these have
become fairly popular benchmarks for use
by by all sorts of folks um probably
most well known is our our big CW we do
over a few years of the kind of entire
Amazon catalog um which contains like
all of the all of the product reviews
and metadata associated with all the
items very widely used data set it's
even pretty popular within Amazon would
you believe um all kinds of stuff like
that so it seems like a mundane
contribution but I think we'll come back
to that later that actually building
these public Benchmark data sets is very
important for machine learning research
um something that can be very hard to do
if you're deal deal with clinical
data um but you know nevertheless this
is kind of one way we've had lots of
impact in our
research okay so that's about it for our
our sort of General machine learning
work next I'll talk about some of the
stuff we've done in clinical machine
learning and yeah most of these are
collaborations with with various folks
from UCSB medical school or you know
other medicine adjacent departments so
we've done a bunch of work on
um like I was just talking about
building Benchmark data sets for
clinical applications very easy to build
Benchmark data sets for um things like
e-commerce applications where data is
very easy to collect widely available
and can be shared with relatively low
risk much harder in clinical settings um
so you know you can imagine the the
years of Labor and the amount of work it
takes to um construct and de identify
and so on and so forth these data sets
and mostly I should say that's not work
done by me you know that's work done by
our collaborators in in the medical
school I think these data sets come from
the the VA um hospital at
UCSD uh
so you know these are not so different
from other natural language processing
benchmarks they're just tailored to
natural language process they're just
tailored to clinical
applications so we're looking at things
like prediction tasks or generation
tasks at the level of sentences and
documents where document generally means
a a clinical note um so tasks like
summarization coding
classification um trying to do what we
call rewriting I'll talk about that a
bit more but it's it's kind of a form of
summarization um identifying ambiguity
in individual sentences identifying um
where the sentences discuss abnormality
or not so building these large data sets
of of ground truth you know other than
other than that doing kind of the the
leg work to be able
to release reusable benchmarks based on
these
things this is a paper that's still
upcoming um okay this is another one
about
um natural language
rewriting uh which is I think pretty
typical of the kinds of collaborations
we've done with with clinical
researchers we had built a model like
this in the context
of um different machine learning
problems unrelated to clinical settings
so we had actually built this model for
looking at letters of reference for our
graduate program we written a paper
about that and the way people can talk
in a biased way about um people based on
their their gender or their nationality
so a person of a from a different
country might might describe a a good
student in in very different terms than
a letter writer from the US for instance
so we wanted to build systems that would
basically rewrite letters of
reference um so that you could not guess
the gender or the nationality of the the
students involved as a form of kind of
debiasing those documents um these days
he probably just ask chat deput to
debias them for you with a nice prompt
but yeah a couple of years ago uh you
had to go to a lot of effort to design
machine learning models for this and we
figured oh actually this kind of model
can be used for other applications
within clinical settings so we wrote
another paper about this where the goal
was to say can we rewrite clinical notes
not necessarily to reduce bias but also
to increase readability so can we have
the model optimize some readability
score on the clinical notes so that you
can write a version of a clinical note
that could be shown to a patient or it
could be interpreted by somebody
Downstream other than a other than a
physician right so you want to rewrite
the note so that it preserves the
important information that you you care
about in other words it's capable of
predicting the the clinical outcome but
it is Rewritten in such a way that it
has a higher higher score in terms of of
um readability or something like
that uh lots of work on I guess what I
call task specific clinical machine
learning is is just one example which
we've written a few papers on about
report generation so you are looking at
an image in this case uh nearly all of
our data is chest x-rays for for one
reason or another I guess that's what we
have a nice data hookup for and we would
like to um generate clinical reports
associated with those
x-rays uh again fairly typical of the
way a lot of our clinical collaborations
have worked I think there's not
necessarily a
huge methodological contribution here
the P this kind of paper is more
like how do we take ideas from computer
vision and natural language processing
that are fairly well established such as
image captioning or these pipelines that
go from images to textual descriptions
of images how do we adapt those to make
them work in clinical settings so if you
just take them off the shelf there are
various reasons um those models won't
work very well and we sort of bring our
have great machine learning expertise to
bear on these problems um so that we can
make them effective in clinical settings
that's kind of what a lot of this sort
of translational
um clinical machine learning research
looks like is sort of saying how do we
adapt existing things that are somewhat
established in traditional machine
learning settings how do we adapt those
to to to clinical applications
uh dealing with things like the the huge
amounts of class imbalance and the fact
that a huge majority of these clinical
reports are not reporting any
significant findings you need to somehow
make the
model not just say oh nothing to report
all the time uh you need it to have you
know good precision and good recall and
highly imbalanced data set so on and so
forth um yeah lots of clinical specific
large anguage model development as well
uh so may not come as a surprise to you
that a lot of these large general
purpose pre-trained language models
don't work very well in clinical
settings um largely because they have
not been trained on clinical data right
they've they've seen lots of data of web
text and people having arguments on
Twitter and so on and so forth but they
have not seen a ton of clinical data um
let alone data in in sort of specific
clinical settings they might have seen a
few um publicly available clinical
natural language data sets but it's not
necessarily what you would have in your
own Corpus or your own hospital system
or anything like that so there is this
um explosion of Interest lately in
training large language models
specifically for clinical data sets or
or certain clinical settings um you know
that's something we've that's a
bandwagon we've been on board
to
um yeah yeah lots of other work along
these lines of building clinical ml
models for these kind of traditional
data modalities again here the challenge
is to
say can we take some clinical
application and some clinical data set
that maybe has some specific
characteristics that make it different
from existing um image classification or
prediction tasks and can we just use our
knowledge of ML and our expertise to
kind of make this work correctly in in a
clinical setting so this paper was about
um predicting the viability of embryos
from these kind of embryo I guess
they're like time lapse videos from a a
system called I think it's called
embryoscope yeah um so you want to
predict whether an embryo is going to be
viable as early as possible
um taking measurements about the embryo
I think is is it's either costly or not
good for the embryo or something so
you'd like to make these these
predictions as as fast as you can the
smallest number of
images um so yeah again this was just
about how can we fuse lots of ideas from
um machine learning and computer vision
how can we figure out how to localize
different parts of an image how can we
run detectors on an image how can we
deal with the fact that these images are
a an ordered sequence uh across some
period of time uh and the
classifications
should should change in kind of a a
smoother or logical way uh it should not
go from saying it's viable to not viable
and back um repeatedly so how can we
kind of Leverage all of
the features about the structure of
these data sets in order to make good
predictions in some clinical
setting uh yeah another paper along
these lines this was about uh scheduling
surgery in an efficient way where we
wanted to build um these regression
models that would use features about the
surgery and about the physician
performing the surgery in order to
estimate how long the surgery would take
but also simultaneously to estimate um
what was our uncertainty about how long
the surgery would take so if you want to
use your your surgical theaters in an
optimal way
um you know you need to you need to
schedule things such
that they're not going to
overrun the amount of time before the
next surgery is due to take place and
that's going to be a function of how
long is the surgery but also what is
your variance so it might be fine to
schedule an extremely long surgery if
your confidence about the amount of time
it takes is extremely narrow right you
know exactly that it will take 3 hours
right um might be safe to to schedule
that at the beginning of the day whereas
something that can sometimes take 10
minutes and sometimes take 3 hours you'd
better be much more careful about
scheduling that early so this is what's
called heteroscedasticity in machine
learning where you want to estimate an
outcome as well as your uncertainty
about the
outcome um if you can do that you can
design more optimal schedulers and yeah
I think nothing mind-blowing here meth
methodologically this idea of
heteroscedasticity is kind of well known
within machine learning we were just
bringing it to bear for clinical
applications um yeah likewise lots of
work taking the the hottest new models
from machine learning in this case it
was recurrent neural Nets applying them
to the problems in in clinical setting
this was a paper about um estimating uh
drug distribution within a patient I
think the drug is
propol uh so you are so um anesthesia
drug basically so you are giving a
patient this this drug and you want to
estimate the drug concentration over
time so that you can dose them
appropriately right um I think this is a
problem that had already been approached
by a bunch of people using machine
learning we were just approaching it
with uh recurrent neural network
specifically this paper's from I guess
2020 I think this was the last paper in
my career where I actually wrote the
code myself um which wasn't a great
experience but we can talk a little bit
more about that if we have a
moment um yeah and other than that we
work on lots of things that I would say
are kind of clinically adjacent so
they're not exactly problems with with
clinical notes or within health systems
or data from health systems or even with
clinical researchers but they're dealing
um with settings that are related to
personalized P so we've done lots of
work on things like um Fitness and
building these models of of Fitness
tracking data which is again widely
available and you can scrape it and
release it to the World um maybe people
don't even realize this when they're
putting their Fitbit on that maybe their
data is actually being stored on a
website somewhere um and yeah you can
imagine if you want to do things like
workout recommendation for people you
need to model personalized Dynamics in
order to do that it would be pretty
useless to have a model of people's
workouts that was not personalized right
so you need to learn how does your heart
rate profile different from that of
another user if you're biking or running
or going uphill or down Hill and so on
and so forth and how can we recommend
personalized exercise routines on that
basis we've also done work on things
like um Public Health uh again with
collaborators in public health at
UCSD okay so that's like a a 10,000 foot
summary of our clinical machine learning
work you can kind of see the different
flavors of it here so lots of work is
kind of this this application of trendy
ml I I would call it so we have the
latest models which at the time might
have meant uh you know recurrent neural
Nets or some type of even you know
certain types of image
classifier um or lately it's generative
language modeling and and natural
language debiasing and things like that
and we are just applying that in
clinical settings so we are bringing
some expertise that maybe we have as
machine learning
academics um to teams uh
who have the the clinical data they have
the problems to work on but maybe they
don't have the same background in
machine learning so this paper IID say
is not you know this this flavor of work
is maybe not like methodologically
groundbreaking it is just adapting the
methodology to clinical settings and
explaining how you adapt machine
learning work uh we do a lot of this
work which I kind of call machine
learning subcontract to work where you
have some clinical data set or setting
that just in some small ways it differs
from standard models so adapting
existing ideas for machine learning it
kind of almost works but doesn't quite
work so like those embryoscope images
it's like oh it's kind of like a image
classification problem but it also has
these issues about dealing with time
series it also has these funny
constraints around how the prediction
should should change over time um so
there's no off-the-shelf model that you
can just use but you need a machine
learning expert to say okay can we
design a bespoke model how should models
be changed to deal with the specific
structure and dynamics of this data set
or this problem
other than that yeah you can see how
lots of these problems overlap with with
personalization so it kind of makes
sense that we work on this stuff given
the other things our lab
does and loads and loads of these
problems in in general machine learning
even things like e-commerce uh you can
kind of see what the the clinical
machine learning counterparts of these
problems are so there's uh lots and lots
of translation between the
two great so that is you know about half
of my time and that is kind of a summary
of um all of the research our lab does
so for the rest of the talk I'm just
going to give life advice
about why we got into this space why I
haven't gotten more into this space what
it was like for me working as a junior
faculty in this space as somebody who
is really a machine learning researcher
or an applied machine learning
researcher but just dipping my foot in
um clinical machine learning
okay so you know why did I get into this
stuff in the first place uh so during my
PhD and most of my postdoc I hardly
touched anything related to clinical
work I was doing um lots of machine
learning problems in computer vision uh
machine learning in social networks and
social media and lots of work on on
recommended systems we had had one or
two collaborations with you know Medical
schols um but not much hardly any and it
certainly came up when I was on the job
market uh and also as Junior faculty
when I was applying for for Grants from
Big
agencies uh people would say you know
why are you doing research that is just
making a few more bucks for Amazon
rather than doing something important um
and I think as a junior faculty member I
kind of take that I sort of took that
criticism seriously and I wanted to do
something that was a bit more quote
unquote important even though maybe my
opinions now are different um so I
thought yeah I should kind of pivot the
lab we're doing all this work about
personalization it ought to be adaptable
to clinical settings so it's something I
should spend a lot more energy getting
involved in so I was very motivated to
adapt the work I'd already been doing on
on personalization and user modeling to
adapt it to clinical settings it really
made a lot of sense to do
so um
second thing and this is just you know
happen stance of of the job I got I was
kind of there at a good time to to get
into this work UCSD at the time had a
computer science department that was
very I don't know how to put it it was
very theoretician heavy I guess so I was
maybe the only really applied machine
learning person on the faculty there had
been one other who was another senior
faculty who who had gone on leave um
um so I was doing this this very applied
machine learning work um that nobody
else was doing and that made me pretty
quickly in demand among say clinical
researchers who were wanting to get into
applied machine learning I was somebody
that got reached out to a lot from from
various folks on campus who were like oh
yeah
we're we're applying for this grant or
we're working on this data set or
problem in involving um data from users
or or sets of clinical notes or
something like that uh can you help us
out with it so I I just became a point
of contact that got looped into a lot of
clinical machine learning projects
because I was there already doing
something that was a little bit
clinically adjacent um and could kind of
be applied and it was pretty easy when
writing these these grants to the you
know whatever funding agencies we were
going for it was pretty easy to claim
that the work work I'd already done on
personal
personalization um was fairly
synergistic with the things we were
trying to work on in clinical notes and
so forth so it wasn't too hard to get
into um but yeah it was you know on the
other hand I didn't have to take too
much initiative myself most of the
initiative was taken by um collaborators
in in
medicine uh yeah other than that I mean
the funding setup was just pretty
synergistic this is how it's kind of
always gone for me with with clinical
collaborations um the clinical
researchers we're working with don't
necessarily have um a lab of of PhD
students in the way a faculty in CS
department does whereas in a CS
Department you know I kind of have this
Army of gsrs
who
um who want to work on these problems
so it has generally been the case that
whenever we' worked on clinical research
it's been our collaborators in the
medical school who've done all of the
work on getting data and funding and
then it's been my lab um and myself that
provides the implementation and the
advice so or the PhD students to do the
work um so it's kind of mutually
beneficial you know they're providing
the the funding and the
data uh and and we're providing the the
graduate student researchers right and
that has certainly helped keep my lab
flat all these years since I've I've
never had my own ni Grant or anything
like
that um other than that I mean students
just actually want to work in this space
certainly with with some of our funded
projects not to name names uh I have to
twist my students arms a little bit to
help out and say look this is funding
the lab please help out with this
project um that's never been the case
with with clinical research uh students
just like me I think they want to work
in this space that um has the appearance
of being higher impact or more
beneficial to society uh they they love
the opportunity to apply their research
to um pinnical machine learning rather
than just applying it to things like
like e-commerce so it's been pretty easy
for me to um ask for help from students
in my lab to work on on these kinds of
clinical machine learning
problems um lovely okay so for the rest
of the talk I'll I'll sort of describe
why I have not transitioned to being
like a full-blown clinical researcher I
mean it's still generally speaking the
case that maybe 10 to 20% of the papers
we publish are about clinical work but
the vast majority are are not and I have
had this ambition maybe to get into this
space more deeply but eventually I
didn't
eventually I I guess I just decided to
accept who I am and embrace my identity
as a as a person who does applied
machine learning work mostly in in
e-commerce so maybe this part of the
talk is a little bit more more negative
but I think it's intended really for
food for thought um just describing my
own experiences I'm I'm happy to discuss
these and to hear some push
back so first of all I think you know
one problem is the research cycle is
just a lot slower in in clinical machine
learning than it is in things like
e-commerce research so it's very easy
for us to collect public data sets from
Amazon or or Google or anywhere you
like um we scrape these ourselves we
write a paper about them we release the
paper uh we release the model associated
with the paper and we release the data
set associated with the paper um people
can very quickly follow up on all of
that um it really fits in well with the
extremely fast research cycle of machine
learning right we want to write papers
that push brand new
methodology that people can quickly
iterate on all of these components as
I'll talk about later are a bit harder
in in clinical machine learning um you
know sometimes getting a data set
together can take months to to years uh
let alone the problem of being able to
release a data set to the public uh
maybe you can release a model but if you
can't release the data set the model
might not be reusable anyway so it's
very hard in clinical settings
to write papers that
will have a ton of reuse and a pushing
brand new methodology uh so yeah it did
it did grind me down a bit where it's
like oh okay it's taking years and years
to really get into clinical research as
a junior faculty member whereas stuff
that's related to e-commerce I can
publish a lot more papers a lot more
quickly and people start kind of citing
them right away because everything's
nice and
reproducible um second point I'd make is
that it's very hard to become
independent as somebody like me uh you
know I've never had my own NIH Grant
I've never even applied for one I should
say but
um I think most of the people like me
who really established themselves as
clinical machine learning researchers so
people who come from machine learning
but primarily work in clinical settings
most of the people who've been
successful in that kind of role have has
special relationships that they can
leverage where they have people they
they continuously work with very closely
in the medical school um you know I have
that too but it's only a small part of
my lab so um it's it would be very
difficult for somebody like me who
research is mostly in e-commerce and has
no clinical clinical background and you
sort of uh at a certain point in my
career has not not had any funding from
Clinical work at least my own funding
from Clinical work it would be very hard
to break into that space
um so I can easily collect funding
related to my core research but any
funding related to clinical work I have
to do with other people and those people
have you there there's certainly more
complex politics about it there's
there's ownership of the data sets and
there a lot of rules involved with using
those data sets and maybe even
complexities about authorship order you
know who knows uh very different from my
experience doing doing work on say
Amazon and Google where we just scrape a
data and The Graduate students write
everything themselves and we never have
to ask permission for everything um it's
a lot easier I hate to
say um you know this is a matter of
opinion but I I would say you know
clinical applications are often more of
a um end point for machine learning
rather than a test bed for machine
learning so if your goal as a machine
learning researcher is to push
state-of-the-art methodology to try out
the latest and greatest models or
actually to design new
models um the kind of papers you publish
in in core machine learning or natural
language processing venues um clinical
settings are an odd place to do that so
yeah for one there are all those issues
I mentioned before about even getting
data sets or the ability to release data
sets and publish papers in the first
place um but there's also maybe just
more of a conservative way of thinking
about these problems where um one does
not wish to apply techniques that are so
experimental but would rather apply
techniques that are a little bit more um
established or proven whereas if you're
doing something like building
conversational recommenders for Amazon
or something well it's like okay the the
stakes are much lower if the thing does
not work perly they're not zero Stakes
but they're somehow lower Stakes so
building wackier or more novel
applications is kind of much it's
sometimes much easier outside of
clinical settings compared to how it is
clinical
settings
um so yeah we've we've generally
written methodology papers for
traditional machine learning and NLP
venues whereas our papers that we
publish in clinical venu are more about
application of existing methodology
rather than driving new methodology your
mileage may
vary um yeah kind of the same point I
mean in terms of having a successful
career
uh success in machine learning
is uh largely measured by the
methodology you develop
rather than by applying methodology to
existing applications so you know if you
want to write nice papers that are are
very highly cited um it helps to be
generating new methodology right so that
is something i' I've personally favored
in in terms of advancing my own career
whereas applying existing methodology to
clinical applications or applications in
public health and so on and so forth um
that might be might be ideal for folks
in the medical school but it's maybe not
what I've wanted to do as much as a as a
CS researcher I definitely want to have
both I want to have application impact
which is why I've wanted to keep all of
these
collaborations with medicine
Etc but mostly I want to have that
methodological impact with machine
learning
great
um yeah I think similar to previous
points I think prototyping is is very
difficult in clinical settings um so if
you just want to test out an idea very
quickly again that's much easier to do
with with data sets you have from from
e-commerce or anything like that um
where you can quickly scrape something
throw something together publish it in a
workshop release the data
set you can do this very quickly you
don't necessarily need funding to do it
you can you can just ask a grad student
to spend a few weeks on it very hard to
have that kind of collaboration with um
clinical researchers if you have a neat
idea you just want to quickly quickly
prototype or try out that's not always
so straightforward the data is not
necessarily there or available you need
to put a lot more leg workor into into
getting a collaboration going for the
reasons I mentioned
previously um yeah I mean
reproducibility I think has been one of
the the toughest points for me uh like I
said we've had so much impact in our lab
just from releasing Benchmark data sets
you know these things like the Amazon
data set even though it's just a data
set of product reviews um it's you know
it gets cited thousands and thousands of
times because people just use it as a
standard Benchmark um every paper we
write in in traditional machine learning
we release the data we release the
models and running the models on the
data ideally should produce the results
reported in the paper um being able to
do work that is reproducible in that way
is in my opinion critically important
and that is much harder to accomplish in
in clinical settings where you do have
all of these issues around release of
data sets and release of
models um certainly in terms of of
impact and getting
citations working with easy to
obtain public data sets has been a lot
easier yeah like I was saying before
there are these quite different metrics
of impact um the the goals or the
standards for promotion or publication
for a computer science researcher who
does some clinical work is going to be
very different than a researcher in a
medical school who is building
applications of machine learning so
those I think are reasonably aligned and
like I say I've benefited a lot from
having all of this clinical work on my
my CV it certainly helped to show we're
also doing translational work building
high stakes
applications
um but yeah you know the number of
papers I have in in a medical journal is
maybe not the most critical thing um
compared to Publications in in machine
learning and NLP core
conferences um you know I think I also
have some opinions which maybe mostly
leave unsaid in the interests of of time
but I think some of the sometimes it's
very hard to work on real problems in
clinical settings like e-commerce might
seem low stakes but it's easy to work on
machine learning problems in e-commerce
that are sort of close to deployment
so if you do work on recommended systems
especially for collaborating with
industry you can easily work on things
that will be deployed in the next few
years or are very close to what industry
is trying to deploy um that is harder in
clinical settings so we do lots of work
on things like image to clinical note
generation so can you automatically
generate a CL clinical note from a
radiology image you know maybe this
would augment the work of a um a
physician or a radiologist or something
but it's it's hard to know um how close
those things are to deployment certainly
none of the clinical machine Learning
Systems we've built have been deployed
inside a hospital right uh and the the
bar for doing so is absurdly high again
due to the due to the stakes involved
let alone all of the bureaucracy around
um deploying uh machine learning
software in a medical system so if your
goal is actually to do translational
deployed research or anything like that
that's actually quite difficult in your
clinical machine learning settings
compared to something maybe lower stakes
and less societally important like like
e-commerce okay so that's that's about
it and I'm about out of time um like I'm
saying that's just my my own perspective
um I am actually much more positive now
as a senior faculty about clinical work
because I can more easily afford
longtime Horizon and very slow research
turnarounds um many of these are
frustrations I had as a junior faculty
member but they just don't really apply
so much anymore as a senior faculty um
you know funnily enough I'm kind of an
outlier my department I don't write any
grants somehow I'm my lab manages to
subsist purely of Industry funding um so
having these longer term sources and
bigger projects around clinical work has
been extremely useful to me it's
something I I plan to sort of keep doing
forever also because the students just
like doing it plenty of students who are
highly enthusiastic to work in this
space uh getting all that momentum going
to do clinical research was was very um
difficult in terms of upfront cost so
I'm really Keen to keep it up um and
yeah I think I'm just sort of getting to
the point in my career where I'm seeing
what the career paths the PhD students
working in this space look like I'm
still a little bit un certain about that
so I think we'll see uh it's been very
easy for students to get jobs I don't
know slinging code for Amazon or so
forth relative to uh getting jobs say as
a as a as a professor or doing doing
clinical research so I'm curious to see
how that goes for this this sort of
batch of students who's just graduating
now who's done most of their PHD on
clinical work um yeah I think advice for
people collaborating with somebody like
me I mean do be mindful um about the
alignment of goals if you're a a
clinical faculty member working with
somebody in a computer science
department um your metrics of impact may
be quite different from from mine right
so yeah I don't know having a having a
paper in a in a in some medical journal
it may be the greatest medical journal
you know of but possibly I've never
heard of it and possibly the people
putting me up in promotion have never
heard of it so it's it's sort of quite
different in terms of how the the impact
is is measured um and those goals can be
a bit tough to align
um yeah I think you do have to be quite
mindful of the sequential dependencies
involved in doing clinical work so yeah
we do have these projects that have been
delayed for years due to data set issues
due to IRB issues not to mention um
funding issues and other issues around
collaborations uh so it is kind of
important to figure all of that stuff
out for planning collaborations too
seriously we've had lots of ostensible
collaborations where students are
actually kind of piddling their thumbs
for most of the year which can be quite
disappointing um final point is you know
I think it is it is very tough to get
these things going without initial
funding like I was saying before
um if you don't have funding for a
project actually building prototypes in
clinical settings can be a ton of work
and somebody has to do it and they have
to do it without without pay so uh it's
it's very hard to get PhD students to do
that and sometimes I sometimes I've
ended up being the one who's had to
write some prototype machine learning
code um and that's always a recipe for
disaster uh I think that's something you
really need to work on is how you
actually set up these initial
collaborations when the funding doesn't
yet exist and the details of the project
aren't B out but you need somebody to
write a machine learning model for you
it's it's actually quite difficult
believe me um but I'll leave it at that
and take questions if there are any
thank you Julian thank you so much for
sharing your the work of your lab and
your kind of advice and life in at the
at the intersection of these two worlds
between kind of like a
traditional computer science machine
learning researcher and how you
interface with folks who are uh working
in the biomed space and I'm curious from
your perspective what can the biomed
Community the clinical research
Community what can we do to make this
more attractive for you is it just to or
or to you know F like yourself or folks
in your lab what what kind of things can
be done to kind of make it look like
this is an area where it's worth
spending a bit more
time um I mean yeah definitely
I would I would phrase it a little
differently it already is very
attractive and it already feels worth
spending our time it's more like oh the
initial attraction wears off quickly
when we realize how difficult it
is um so yeah students want to work in
this space uh and they do feel like it's
worthwhile and yeah they don't always
just want to work on e-commerce or
things like that um but it's so hard to
get started the the bureaucracy around
data is so difficult um you know also
around the ownership of of data and
models and where things can be deployed
um I think there's the obvious stuff
like just making things like IB is a bit
more smooth um having the data
collaborations already set up so having
access to compute and servers where you
can run the data having that not be some
weird nightmare where the student has to
go to a physical room where they're
accessing the data but like oh
everything's on AWS or something like
that so a platform that
computer science researchers are
familiar with um so we can quickly get
working on things I hope the situation
improves itself a little bit just with
increased availability of public
Benchmark data sets that can be used in
the
meantime um I'd say also yeah in
practice we do spend a lot of time
working on on proxy problems you know we
work on problems where the the data set
characteristics are similar but they're
not clinical data sets
so if you're working on something like
language debiasing you might have an end
goal of doing this within a clinical
setting but you might actually try and
find data sets that are are non-clinical
right that are around something like
yeah student admissions or hiring or
something um that you can kind of work
on and have impact in the
meantime um other than that I mean you
have to make it tempting it's like if
you want to develop prototypes and
things it would it's certainly easier if
there is budget available to do so it's
it's very difficult to ask students or
can we quickly try and prototype
something for the purpose of applying
for some Grant in the
future uh oh and also you have to TA in
the meantime because this project isn't
funded yet that's really tough
um so yeah I've had those flavors of
collaborations kind of be the LA because
it's like yes we need to develop
prototype we want to apply for some
funding we don't have any money right
now um and you I think there can be some
misalignment in terms of how much work
it is to actually develop um a quick ml
prototype or
something that's a bit of a brain dump
hopefully you got something out of that
response thank you um what do you you
know from you know you're more of a
senior faculty member now and you talked
about you know what you see as career
paths for young investigators who may or
may not be working at this interface of
machine learning and and uh and
biomedical science um but what do you
think this interface looks like in in
say five years or over the next five
years you want to make a
prediction um I don't know I mean I
certainly I think clinical natural
language processing is is overtaking
everything um just as generative
language models are overtaking a lot of
our traditional recommended systems
projects you know it wouldn't surprise
you to hear that most of our clinical
machine learning projects are also about
generative language models and
conversational interfaces and things
like
that um For Better or Worse people are
very interested in this so a lot of
these more complex bespoke pipelines
dealing with things like clinical Note
data or even even um image plus text
applications are being replaced by by
general
purpose um large language models or
Foundation models deployed within
clinical settings
um so I think that's at least where the
where the research and the funding is
very quickly
going um that's been kind of a c change
in the last year uh I would say you know
we've had some some more promising
projects recently
where
um yeah we do have sort of more yes I
think with that kind of research there
is this realization that um doing
clinical machine learning learning does
come with
these
big resource and compute budgets and you
need to be really Ser serious about how
the data is set up and accessed um so in
a way that's been easier for us because
it's it's looked more like the kind of
research we're familiar with as machine
learning
people
um yeah whether any of this pans out
whether people are really using uh
generative language models within
clinical settings I don't know I think
there's also plenty of more mundane and
and boring problems that leverage
generative Ai and clinical natural
language processing even if you just
using language models to extract better
features from from data sets so rather
than writing these very careful and
detailed passes that try and figure out
outcomes from Clinical notes you can
just ask language models to do it for
you um but yeah certainly that from from
where I'm sitting um like translation of
large language models and Foundation
models to to clinical data sets is is
the big
shift yeah that sounds like there's a
lot of promise there especially for
these you know recommender systems kind
of taking some of the things that you
are learning about in uh you know the
bias mitigation um sounds like that's
very appropriate for you know dealing
with very technical often colloquial
clinical language in say you know
physician notes or in medical records
and turning those into one things people
can read but then making sure that uh
they are as bias free as they can get is
probably a good place to kind of I don't
know put one's money if one were a
gambler well listen Julian thank you so
very much for sharing your experiences
with us sharing some you know what you
see is possibly some challenges but
opportunities as well for young people
getting into this space and um I think
it's I think it's fantastic and we look
for you know further input from EXP
experts like yourself about how best to
leverage uh what's on the Leading Edge
of machine learning and Ai and these
generative models uh in the biomedical
space because we're it's it's as
important in this space as it is in you
know Financial systems or or you know
selling of stuff on Amazon so yeah
cheers my excellent have a wonderful
weekend Julian have a wonderful weekend
everybody who's joined us and uh we will
not be having a um biomedical
uh uh data science seminar series next
week due to the observation of Veterans
Day so uh we will see you in two weeks
time so uh have a wonderful and lovely
weekend we'll see you all soon thanks
again Julian